[Music]
Jeff Snyder here at the Kia telluride
supper sweet in Park City and I am here
with the director and star of dream
horse which got a great reaction I feel
like yeah it was really exciting I mean
you know so always nerve-wracking when
you show you film for the first time
last night audience at Salt Lake City
they couldn't have been warmer they
laughed they cried they whooped honestly
how many times I've been to Sundance it
was an unbelieving so Park City crowd
was also right up there responding in
the same way so it's the story the true
story of Jan Volks who lives in a little
village in a place called Wales which is
where I'm from and she works behind the
bar at a local club she also works in
the supermarket and she has a dream of
owning a racehorse and nobody has any
faith that she can pull this off because
she's not a millionaire she's not an
aristocrat but she persuades everybody
in the village to chip in ten pounds a
week into a syndicate they get a full
raise him on the back yard who turns out
to be this incredible champion did you
say it was a true story yeah true story
attracted you to this role because it's
the most perfect underdog story of all
time the script the story itself is just
so warm it's so positive and I think
seeing someone who who has a very simple
humble life achieving a dream like that
is an incredibly inspirational story
it's so empowering and in no way
manipulative and it just makes you feel
fantastic the way the audience liked
even I mean I was there as they're
making it last night I was sobbing like
it out of joy as well you know it's a
beautiful story had you seen the
documentary before the script came
across no I had i watched it once i was
kind of signed on to do it yeah okay so
I wanted to ask because you know I've
read that it is really a feel-good
warm-hearted movie and these are some
dark times that we're going through
right there's there's war there's
viruses all over how important is it to
enjoy
you know this kind of good-natured
entertainment into the world yeah well I
think it's our job as filmmakers and
storytellers to lead the way and you
know politics is downstream of culture
we come first and and set the tone so
it's it's our job to to lift the heart
of the audience and I think this film
sets out to do that to have a story of
hope
and I hope that when the audience comes
out of that cinema that they'll be
uplifted with him and it's you know
society tends to kind of isolate and
we're all in our phones living
ostracized lives and this is about
community coming together with one goal
and it's you know I think it's a
necessary thing for people to see in
this time do you guys have a favorite
horse-racing movie is there anything
that comes to mind I love there's a
British film called champion about a
jockey called bob champion and it's got
the most amazing racing sequences which
I might have crimped some shots from
okay I remember watching foul-up when I
was a kid which is an Australian
champion this is horse racing not
horseback riding but you guys have any
experience with horses yourselves I had
a wonderful foal when I was 23 dragged
all on her beach I did however get back
on the horse but then I had to lie down
for a few weeks
yeah and I'm a horse novice I knew very
little about horses but for me the the
films about a dream more than it is
about horse racing I mean the horse
racing is important and it's important
to thrill the audience but you know it's
about a connection and what this horse
does for the entire community it changes
their lives for the better
I just remembered one incredible
experience I had with horses I was in
Ireland and I went for this big walk on
a friends property and I was always just
a lot like several hours five hours
something like that walking on my own
and as I came back up I could I looked
up and they were literally like 40 wild
horses just standing Stockstill staring
at me and it was kind of intimidating
but I'd been hugging trees hanging out
with nature so they came right in like
it was so beautiful so I'm glad I ran in
this film
Jan her connection with the horse is
really important and she she opens her
heart to the horse and shares her
deepest secrets and and you and that
horse I did have a connection the horses
at real name Oh beautiful beau have
either of you ever had to persuade a
neighbor to help you with anything I
remember as a boy trying to sell raffle
tickets to neighbors it was always a
pain did you ever have to canvass the
neighborhood and ask folks for help
believe I have done that in my street we
have um we have lots of trees and every
every fall that the street gets
absolutely full of leaves that block the
drain sir so and every for we all come
out with our brooms and and brush the
street and it and it it's the one
everybody starts to ten years and I met
people I never spoke how you have
directed some huge television shows
I mean Doctor Who Sherlock black mural
broadchurch daredevil I'm just naming
some what you know what I did not know
that how did that experience directing
all this prestige TV prepare you to
directory I mean when I approach a piece
I'm always you know I want to tell the
truth about what that story is and get
at the truth and work with actors
fantastic actors to help them understand
what it's like to be a human in that
particular story and and I think that's
what is a common theme through all these
really different shows and and it's what
I brought to dream cause I tend to like
to work on things that make people
remember that they're alive because we
are so numb to ourselves
you forget we have a finite period of
time here and so this story particularly
you know just to I think it's so
important to have a crack at what you're
passionate about in life because if you
don't try you don't get another go this
is it and that's why this film is so
exciting to me that's that's what the
story's about and you currently star in
an Oscar contender knives and Johnson
what was it did that made that script so
special for you
you never knew what was coming it was
there were so many twists and turns it
was so witty
I loved my character I loved all the
characters they were just despicable and
wonderful and so much fun to play yeah
it's just really smart very fun and to
film very joyous experience yeah you're
also working with a reigning Best
Picture winner in Yermo del toro on
nightmare alley what can you tell us
about that project and when you know why
you want to work with your mom because
he's a complete visionary a true auteur
he's amazing and he has a very
infectious energy I loved his films I've
liked him when I've met him the script
is excellent and I would say yes to
anything so that he was offering me I
haven't started yet so I said I started
about a month not much to report you did
just wrap another Charlie conference I'm
thinking of ending things what can you
tell me about that that's in the can it
is girls no I don't be careful I loved
working with him he's such a sweetheart
and he just he does very clearly and
obviously to all of us think out of the
box and it was a very kind of small
focus to shoot it's basically a cast of
four people and it's kind of bonkers
okay so that's next for you what's next
for you era I'm reading some scripts
okay dreaming up my next project yeah
guys thank you for coming in the team
behind dream horse thank you to Kia
supper suite for sponsoring us and guys
have a wonderful festival